SIV beyond Earth feels much different
from sieve five right away when you land
on planet you're immediately met with
his hostile aliens and of course you
have barbarians and SIF five but this is
gonna feel a lot different we're huge
fans of both science and science fiction
so we wanted to make sure the game
starts in a believable place but it
starts moving out very quickly and
taking these little steps into the more
fantastic so for that we looked you know
far and wide especially the Canon of
classic sci-fi Lyra true there's really
no shortage of great sci-fi material out
there is drew from one of the things
that we had a great time doing was
figuring out who the cast of characters
is going to be and the way we did that
is we started with the geopolitical
landscape of Earth as it is right now
and introduced this thing that we called
the great mistake the result of that was
this reshuffling and mass migration of
people so the nations sort of
reassembled themselves and clawed their
way out of this Dark Age and it's at the
point where they're finally back on
their feet again that the game begins
where they're sending spaceships to new
worlds
their leaders represent this
multicultural mixing that happens a lot
of them speak a mixture of languages for
example the American reclamation
corporation how may the corporation
serve you the sponsor that you can pick
for that
Suzanne fielding speaks a combination of
spanish and english sort of
interchangeably impossibly a lot like
how everybody swears in Chinese and
Firefly you know it tells a lot about
what happened without saying much so the
tech web is probably the most
fundamental change to this game tech is
really the engine of civilization and in
stores if it falls a pattern that most
people already recognize but in this
game you're moving forward into an
uncertain future which has technologies
that we obviously haven't invented yet
so we wanted to make a structure that
would let the player play explorative Li
and kind of discover along the way what
technologies were going to be useful or
advantageous or just interesting to them
and the type we have is so big that you
will not get all the technologies in the
course of any one game which is another
departure from historic sin but then you
start again and end up with a completely
different blend that makes their date
more exploratory and also more reliable
the orbital layer is a really exciting
addition to civilization the ground is
always the star of the show and the
orbital layer is there to reinforce that
drama that's going on underneath so when
you land on the planet almost right away
you can go back into the orbit around it
and put up tactical or economic or
research satellites they're going to
augment or change up the situation on
the ground so you know defend yourself
from invasion or make your cities into
economic powerhouses or spy on your
neighbors and steal things from them
that's just one of several fundamentally
new ways to play the game after we
announced the game it was really special
to sit in that room at PAX East with 700
with our biggest fans it was especially
gratifying because we receive fans to
who grew up on those games and loved
those games and this game was really
inspired by that it's really a our thank
you to the fans who've been asking us to
make this game for a long time and we
wanted to make for a long time
you